hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan in today's episode
I'm going to answer a question from one
of my four meters dawn road and asking
about success and he said as an
entrepreneur what has been your biggest
success online so thanks for the
question dawn for me my big success i
think is the launch of every chemical
calm and turning that into a business so
when i sold my first software company
and hooked up with a venture capital
company i was being asked to do a lot of
speaking as a young entrepreneur kind of
success story so i use my website at my
chemical calm basically just to say
where i was speaking and what I was
talking about as well as share some of
the famous entrepreneur profiles I had
found helpful for me when growing my
business people who I modeled their
successes of the build successful
company myself as well and that was the
launch of the website and no matter what
I was always am had that website I felt
it was adding value back the people who
were reading and people would right in
saying that they really loved what i
wrote and it was inspiring and you know
motivated them to keep going with their
business and not give up and you know
that's awesome stuff right that makes me
want to keep going and doing more and
when you get feedback like that you know
you're doing something right you're on
the right track it was never intended to
be a business at the start I was just
something that I did as value ID to help
people out and a lot of people helped me
with my business that I started so I
wanted to get back and it also felt
really good knowing that you're helping
people and then when i discovered hey
you know why we can try some advertised
on the website and that did well that
kind of made the click with the website
and that started the process for it to
become my next main business and so I
transitioned out of the great chick a
pro company and did my I mechanical calm
stuff on the side while at the VC firm
and when I noticed hey this this has
some serious revenue opportunities as
well and if I can do what I'm really
excited
go and make money doing it and help a
lot of people it's awesome formula and
that it was able to no leave the venture
capital company and pursue a from
CARICOM fall time and turn it into a
real business and that's when I'm you
know really proud of really probably my
biggest success online we've done a lot
of little things to make it better and
better better on an increasing basis
every day we try to do things to make
the company better but from a big
picture point of view I think be able to
launch at millicom and get a lot of
people coming to it and be able to turn
into a business it's probably my biggest
success online so thanks for the
question dawn if you guys liked the
video please give a thumbs up and makes
me to do more of these videos for you
guys and if people question about
success or another question for your
company feel free to leave it in the
comments below I always read those and
how to respond as many as I can so thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode
you